the world's largest active volcano
Hawaii's Mauna Loa is attracting a new
Rush of tourists after its latest
eruption look at those pictures those
that's real stuff so far the spectacular
display is not threatening any populated
areas that's good but the governor has
declared an emergency Mauna loa's
neighbors are preparing now for any
possible impact Jonathan Vigliotti has
the latest from Hawaii's Big Island
new Fountains of lava roughly 10 stories
high gushed out of Mauna Loa Tuesday the
world's largest active volcano began
erupting on Sunday for the first time in
almost 40 years
this time lapse video shows glowing lava
running down its slopes turning the
night sky red scientists say two new
lava flows formed yesterday and managed
to cross a private road cutting off
power and access to the maunaloa
observatory facility it does appear to
be making a pretty strong flow at the
moment experts are keeping a close eye
on the lava's movement which is about
six miles from Saddle road connecting
the East and West sides of the island it
could just as easily shift and start
another flow as well and we'll just
watch it very very carefully we're
thinking very very much about you know
advances the State Health Department
says the eruption could cause Ash and
sulfur dioxide to negatively impact air
quality across the state but the Hawaii
Volcanoes National Park is still open
and he's drawing in Spectators eager to
see the flows many are hoping to witness
a volcanic double whammy both Mauna
loa's eruption and kilaueas a smaller
more active volcano which are updated in
2018 destroying hundreds of homes on the
island this is a rare time where we have
two eruptions happening simultaneously
to the people of Hawaii this is a very
sacred event that we are watching for
CBS morning's Jonathan Vigliotti on the
island of Hawaii
it's amazing nobody has been hurt you
look at the visuals and you think how
it's a big volcano that's been there a
long time I think they know not to build
around it right so what was there is no
longer there it's always somebody
curious that stinks let me get a little
closer let me get a picture yeah because
you only see stuff like that in movies
yeah yeah 10 10 foot 10 story tall
volcanic eruption that's just wild it
really is wild